[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 97 q and a it
is caturday although our cat has just
left the studio no he left we did he's
off to deputy to produce something
yep okay um we're going to try to keep
it to an hour today um because we have
been in front of the screens
so much we really have so much uh we
might even go less than an hour let's
just see we'll see the discord question
this week so every week uh people in
either of our patreons get access to our
discord and people in the discord pose
questions and then they vote on them and
we answer one question from the discord
every week
this week's question is why isn't the
way that marijuana modulates ace ii
pathways which seem to play a major role
in the inflammation caused by kevin 19
being looked at by science
that question um was surprising to me i
hadn't um hadn't occurred to me and now
of course i don't know why i can't find
what i'm looking for the one thing that
i found that seems to suggest that some
scientists are investigating this was
this pre-print zach if you would show
now this is a this is something that's
been a pre-print since april 2020 so i
don't know what that means about um
about
its future or uh whether or not the
authors still consider this robust
um but the title
is in search of preventative strategies
novel anti-inflammatory high cbd
cannabis sativa extracts modulate acetyl
expression in coban 19 gateway tissues
and
the the idea is
that it is thought that
sativa in particular
um not steve in particular but cbd in
particular being the um molecule that
seems to modulate
um ace2 expression uh may therefore
effectively um impair the ability of
sarge kovi 2
to
use those same pathways to infect people
and then these authors are developing
sativa strains that that they think may
be particularly effective
this is consistent with some stuff that
we were talking about early in the
pandemic like april may i think of 2020
uh right around when this was uh first
time it was a pre-print not that we knew
that um where this seemingly paradoxical
uh result about
uh former smokers uh were at some
considerable risk i think if memory
serves
from developing coven 19 but current
smokers actually seem to have something
protective and it turns out that
nicotine
also um nicotine like uh cannabis uh
seems to be involved in the regulation
of the um
ace ii uh expression so
you know maybe that's consistent with
this but that's sort of all i've got at
the moment the question is why is
science not investigating it okay um
yeah
what i would say is
first of all i'm not sure that it's the
pathway you want to go down if we had
nothing else okay but basically if i
understand it correctly the idea is that
cbd alters the rate of expression of the
ace2 receptor genes which means that it
interferes with normal functionality in
what they're calling covet gateway
tissues
now it could be that in a pandemic
that's worth doing that the cost of
altering those tissues that they
function sub-optimally is worthwhile i
mean you know costs and benefits and all
things
but it isn't obvious that you need to do
this
so i would just point people
uh to
if you look at the desert news recently
did
a
an extensive discussion on the
difference between indian states and
their rates of covid and once again it
tells us what we've been telling you
here which is that we have tools that
work
so the question is why are we not using
the tools that work
and i don't know what the answer to that
question is i find it shocking that we
wouldn't be it could be incompetence
although at a breathtaking does it
review level uh
it's gonna be the desert review
yeah valley yeah and look uh is this it
i can't tell okay i don't think so but
um
in any case there was a an article about
the difference between indian states
those that have embraced early treatment
and those that have rejected it and
those that have embraced early treatment
and prophylaxis have driven their rates
of covid through the floor
uh so
yeah so this this is gonna be it i think
zach you can show this quickly this is
the desert review with an article called
india's ivermectin blackout published
august 9th updated september 8th um so
talking about the different results in
different indian states anyway uh i
think the point is it sort of seems like
we have a policy in which we oppose that
which works and that seems bad uh i it's
hard to imagine what else we can say
except um if we've got that level of
breathtaking incompetence we ought to do
away with it and if it's not
incompetence then we ought to be asking
what is driving but um but damn
but damn but damn yeah um so anyway i
guess the answer to the discord question
is
uh
yes if it was all if it was the only
hopeful sign the only hopeful pathway of
course it should be studied and probably
should be studied anyway but is it the
path forward no we've got paths forward
and we're not using them so
yep so what gives
all right uh
first question from the darker
submissions.com site this week would the
dark horse moderator be willing to put
me in touch with other dark foals who
wish to join forces in saving their
friend from the woke in my case it's
trans let's pool our experiences we can
reach them through understanding
consider this the start of the save your
friends initiative they are too
important to lose to the woke
so there's not exactly a question there
except to the darkhorse moderator yeah
about you know how i'm not sure that our
mod has the
i'm not i don't know what that should
look like we've definitely talked before
about um
facilitating people finding one another
and it's important
um i'm not sure
um
uh one way would be through the
distortion yeah i guess um one way would
be
the discord although there's a little
bit of um
not purely functional stuff going on
there at the moment apparently
um
so
yes in terms of the spirit of this and
uh we have been it has not been top of
our mind but we have been on again off
again trying to figure out how to
facilitate people getting in touch with
one another because there are lots
lots of you out there who would like to
find each other but yeah i think the
discord is a good at least first pass
yep yeah
next question
i overheard colleagues at work laughing
at the death of an elderly republican
who was apparently against covid
what do you think happens if we get
through this to the people who have
embraced the cruelty allowed by current
facts anti-vaxx lockdown anti-lockdown
dehumanizing narratives a lot of ashamed
people people in denial
what uh what other possibilities
i would expect intense denial
i i think yeah reframing of what
people's positions actually were yeah
people will people have dropped one
ambiguous thing into social media at one
point and they'll point to that and say
see i wasn't i wasn't so sure yeah no i
i think we have a terrible problem here
because people have uh
their compassion has been turned off as
we've talked about before that's a
familiar pattern in history it precedes
certain kinds of
terrible events atrocities and the like
and so having had that triggered
and then
maybe getting back to a normal mind
frame at some point they will
either compartmentalize and not realize
what they had become or yeah they will
have terrible existential crises and i
think that the uh the former is much
more likely
yeah and i mean i think you you know
they will they will
deny it and not see
what how it is that they are behaving or
an existential crisis and i think that
that second option the existential
crisis is what the person asking the
question
the option that they provide their
language for that existential crisis is
a lot of ashamed people and i think this
is this is worth potentially exploring a
little bit that shame
shame has a value right like shame has
been abused for sure um by authorities
and in you know in religions and schools
and you know other systems across time
um and and used to control behavior
where behavior should not have been um
being controlled um but shame has an
adaptive value and you know just just
like um
grief feels awful and the response to
feeling awful should not be must get rid
of feeling um but rather
feel the grief that you feel so that you
you know in the case of grief depending
you know so that you
you remember as much as possible um of
the person or animal who is gone and um
and you and you learn the lessons that
need to be learned rather than simply
forgetting them so as not to be
uncomfortable so similarly shame you
know these these emotions that we think
of as negative um that doesn't mean that
they are
to be avoided we try to avoid them
we should not be trying to avoid the
symptoms of the thing we should be
avoiding the thing that is causing them
so if you have reason to feel ashamed
um you should actually require of
yourself that you that you exist in that
feeling for a while such that you are
less likely to make the error that you
made that brought you to the shame in
the first place yeah and you know with
all that caveat up front about shame has
been often used by um various systems to
to oppress and that's that's not an
honorable use no
uh
there are misfirings of all these things
and abuses but negative emotions
negative sensations are adaptive and
the idea of them is to steer you towards
behavior that fixes an actual problem
not to get you to anesthetize them
yeah that's all yep
are there ecosystems dependent on
occasional hurricanes
aside from any effects of the
intervening technology would eliminating
or weakening hurricanes be a net
positive or negative
the problem is in your concept of
dependent on
i have no doubt that there are many
ecosystems that would be radically
altered if you eliminated hurricanes i'm
thinking of uh
low-lying wetlands barrier islands
all of these things but um so you know
they could be altered and it could be
that there are species that are so
dependent on those ecosystems that their
alteration would cause some extinctions
i don't know if that would happen but it
might
but the point is ecosystems change
through time and
the fact that they change doesn't
necessarily mean that they've been
destroyed you know it's sort of a
confusion
entering the same river twice kind of
question
um so what i would say is
you can't really address it this way do
do have some habitats evolved in light
of periodic hurricanes and that causes
some sort of equilibrium that would be
disturbed probably but i don't think
it'd be
uh i don't think we can say it would be
negative but you're looking at me with
some look like i've made some
no crazy error no i just i expected you
to go a slightly different direction so
i'm going to prod you to go in that
direction all right i want you to define
and then steal man the inter
intermediate disturbance hypothesis
yeah okay the intermediate disturbance
hypothesis uh
multiply proposed yes two separate uh
proposals of it eighties maybe
yeah
yeah i think so in any case
it is the hypothesis that diversity is
maximized by
intermediate levels of
disturbance
and the idea being that in very low
intermediate in either space or time i
think right and
hurricanes having been proposed as as
one source of diversity enhancing um
darwin's hostile force in tropical
coastal ecosystems right the basic idea
and there's actually a such a beautiful
experiment that demonstrates that
there's at least substantial truth in
this hypothesis which i'll tell you
about if i can remember it in a second
but
the basic idea is
a low diversity a low
level of disturbance causes a low level
of diversity because some superior
competitor drives out all the others
they go to extinction and so you get a
very small number of competitors
a high level of disturbance uh basically
drives down the number of creatures that
can tolerate the environment right if
it's too chaotic then things get driven
extinct by the hostile forces and the
intermediate levels we see high
diversity and the beautiful experiment
which i believe was
the ecologist
the bob paine i think it is bob payne
not the ornithologist um i'm not sure
yet but in any case
experiment involved i really this is one
of my favorites um gluing down rocks in
the intertidals
so the idea was that rocks in the
intertidal zone um roll around with
waves really big rocks don't roll around
hardly at all and little rocks roll
around a lot and medium-sized rocks roll
around a bit
and so the basic point was you could see
the diversity patterns on the different
sizes of rocks and you could infer that
they were the consequence of the level
of disturbance but you could test this
by taking rocks that should roll around
more and causing them to roll around
less by gluing them down which then
caused the diversity to fall which is
super beautiful and
experimentally elegant and uh not high
tech i would point out no this is how
really good science works in an
environment um of uh i don't know
muscles and other intertidal
creatures absolutely um
you found it no i found a 2007 paper
that's sort of a latter-day
uh abundance diversity and fidelity of
macro invert sheltering beneath rocks
during tidal immersion and intertidal
cobalt field does the intermediate
disturbance hypothesis hold for less
exposure smaller rocks but i thought
from there i could get here but there's
just a there's so many references that
i'm not finding it
um cobble size i see a connell it wasn't
connell connell was one of the original
intermediate disturbance hypothesis but
not this but that's not the empirical
work yeah yeah as if i'm sure it's in
here but there's just a lot there's um
rough garden did some stuff too i
remember now
um
that would have been rough garden yeah
well 98 actually yeah well that's joan i
think at that point um test of the
prediction of the immediate disturbance
hypothesis has connell listed here for
1970. well maybe i'm wrong maybe who did
the experiment i'm not anyway but anyway
um so the reason heather was smiling me
that way is that i have a love hate
relationship with this hypothesis i know
it to be true and important but it has
been invoked to explain the latitudinal
diversity gradient and it has which is
the latitudinal diversity gradient is
the tendency of species numbers and
species density to go up as you get
closer to the equator which is something
i studied because from the moment that
a world-class ecologist told me that we
didn't know why that pattern existed i
thought wait a second something is wrong
because this pattern exists everywhere
how how could we possibly not know the
answer to that question why is that
question not being investigated so
anyway i did a dissertation chapter on
it and i found that the claim of
intermediate disturbance that was
supposedly supporting the
tropical forest habitats being so high
diversity they were using tree falls as
their disturbance their part of their
disturbance regime
um which
are yes disturbing but also a
consequence of the higher diversity and
they're especially when you're under
them as you have one
yes the trees have been out to get me
for some time but
um but anyway uh so anyway there's a
circular argument in there and when you
eliminate the tree falls it's a
relatively low
uh disturbance habitat that still has
high diversity
if if memory serves i mean you you went
to sort of all of the um promising
leading hypotheses for the latino
diversity gradient and it wasn't another
problem with intermediate disturbance
hypothesis that even if it were true in
those tropical forests
which you know the circularity of the
tree falls suggests that we just don't
know um it didn't hold inside it didn't
hold in the oceans yeah that's the thing
yeah it's not the tree falls that are
doing it because because the little
reefs for example are extremely high
diversity habitats yeah and there's no
analog and so anyway yeah there's a lot
wrong with that literature but you know
i mean the intermediate disturbance of
the literature welcome to the literature
intermediate disturbance was one of
those things it's not like that's a
wrong hypothesis that's a right
hypothesis that just doesn't apply
doesn't explain what they're claiming no
and in fact that world class ecologist
who you mentioned who was the person who
kind of sent you down this path was john
vandermeer
and he also was the one who introduced
us to the intermediate disturbance
hypothesis and he had worked
in um
coastal nicaragua after i don't remember
what your hurricane or even exactly what
year but he had happened to have had
work um
pre-hurricane and then it just got
battered and so he was able to you know
watch the recovery rates of these four
of this forest for many years um
effectively happened to have you know
been doing work in the right place to to
study regeneration and such and
um
and
i think if i if memory serves he you
know
he sort of wanted to be a fan of
hypothesis but couldn't quite um find a
ton of support even in his um in his
data set i think i think is what yeah i
don't i don't actually remember what he
what he found but you know john was
always uh
i thought excellent at
seeing
the partial truth in things that were
partially true without embracing it or
rejecting it totally no absolutely
i don't know who this is but i'll ask
the question would you be interested in
a conversation with neil oliver thank
you and congratulations on your book
do your name's not ringing a bell yeah
um can't answer that until unless we
know who that is
shouldn't we
shouldn't we decolonize western
medicines by using medicines discovered
by a non-western person of color and not
a tool created by a white european
colonizer
in fact that's all we should do
it's the only thing we should do i think
we should just do that and uh see if it
solves all of our problems
um yes obviously that is a facetious
question yeah um we should use whatever
works and
it doesn't matter where it came from in
fact
we have plenty of ideas that are central
to our thinking that were uh generated i
know this is going to shock some people
but by people who weren't perfect
sometimes people who are desperately
imperfect like statistics do you like
statistics statistics are great they
allow you to know what the hell is going
on however
they were uh invented by a
an anti-semite all right fisher yeah all
right fisher so anyway total tool
partial tool
[Laughter]
oh i mean and he he made great
contributions in evolutionary theory too
sex pressure theory um you know
fantastically important uh mind in um
that has contributed to our
understanding of the world and a tool
you know what i don't like of his
this toolness the anti-semitism and the
toolness
yeah those are both things i've never
never felt positive about but
the you know for example sex ratio
theory very useful stuff very useful
yeah
stood the test of time sure has for good
reason unlike some of his
unfavorable personality traits
a woman with the line i spread like
syphilis in her song is going to war for
first amendment rights how is it we're
here
how is it we're here indeed this is uh
nicki minaj i'm probably mispronouncing
her name no i think you've pronounced it
perfectly yeah
um but i mean i've seen wow
wow how is it we're here
at some level she's uncancelable and
this is what we were actually this is a
point we didn't get to when talking
about michael shermer right like yes um
so let's let's do that a little bit
very unfortunate that michael shermer is
now
being fused with nicki minaj sorry
michael um yeah very sorry about that
we also have defects of personality and
apparently timing
and here we are um yeah i don't know i
mean the fact is i mean everyone
everyone should aspire to being
uncancible and many people don't have
the way or the means but it's it it
affords you an ability to have
a microphone and not having it stolen
not have it stolen from you yes and
maybe maybe it
provides
some cover but
look i think we need to note what moment
we're in right the fact that nicki minaj
is somehow involved in
one of the most serious discussions
he's been invited to the white house
apparently i don't know maybe i'm wrong
i
obviously this is not how things are
supposed to work and obviously it's not
functional right right um right you know
it's nicki minaj
reporting an anecdote right right so
which means if the anecdote turns out to
be in any way untrue then that will be
taken as evidence by the mainstream
media that everything that could
possibly have been downstream of the
anecdote if it were true cannot be true
either but i i think which is a failure
of statistical thinking which again was
largely invented by a truly horrible
human being who had a great mind
see earlier point yeah yeah right um
yeah i think i think the point that you
were making is the right one which is
you have
a world full of people
they have a
range of expertise on the topics of the
moment and they have a range of
cancellability right and the people with
the expertise are not finding themselves
uncancelable which has silenced many and
has caused others to speak up and be
cancelled and that has left nicki minaj
as one of the most expert people who is
fully not cancelable left and therefore
and fully in possession of an anecdote
that may or may not be true
whether or not if it were true it would
suggest something real about underlying
patterns
i guess the point is i know nothing
about this this person um but i you know
i i doubt that she has a firm grasp on
the difference between anecdote and data
and and what it might mean i don't know
i know i don't like what she does for a
living but i don't care the point is
what's really but i mean in terms of
like as a spokesperson but the person
being brought to the white house but
that that that isn't the point the point
is
you have by allowing mobs to rule who
gets to speak what they get to say what
platforms they're allowed to speak on
you're left with nicki minaj in charge
of public health policy right and that's
not what you want right or in charge of
the heterodox view on public health
policy
right what you want are people who
actually know something about this and
have the tools and i don't think nicki
minaj is claiming to i think she just
ends up as somebody who's
just like actually no i'm not gonna shut
up thank you no right
so anyway um
not sure what else to say about it this
is not an you know again i i'm i'm
perfectly happy on a normal day to
attack nicki minaj based on the product
she puts into the universe and no you
don't you don't you don't attack people
i don't attack people but i would i
would attack the product i don't think
it's a positive contribution absolutely
you know
uh that's neither here nor there she's
hardly distinguished in putting things
into the world that aren't positive
contributions right um but the fact is
it is her uncancelableness that has put
her central central to this controversy
and that says something about the
sickness of the environment she's used
perverse incentives and um unregulated
market forces to get to the top in a
field um that is distinguished only for
its sort of reprehensibility and that
has given her uncancelability and uh and
now she's saying actually no i saw a
thing and i'm not gonna shut up about it
and um
more of us need
the freedom
to say actually no i'm not going to shut
up about it
yep
hi heather and brett thoughts on the fda
panel rejecting boosters for mainstream
population 14 to 65 without health
conditions on friday uh by the way i'm
on chapter five
yeah um it's fascinating development
fascinating development after two
high-profile resignations by people who
then went on to be authors on a paper in
the lancet and i don't know what did the
lancet paper
show uh i haven't seen the lancet paper
see if i can see if you can but i'm
gonna need more than just
um unfortunately i'm not in a position
to help you with that in fact i don't
even have their names uh at top of mind
but
what i would say is i don't think we
know what any of this means obviously
this is not on script you have
so it's going to be uh tyrion gruber and
phil krauss
i am uncertain okay so i'm finding those
names in new york post
of all places
telling politico et cetera et cetera and
then if i take those names
to google scholar and look up lancet you
think it's lancet yep okay so you think
it's the lancet but anyway we are we are
somewhere new this is you know high
profile resignations in advance of a
high profile uh letter critical of the
idea that boosters would be useful
obviously
makes a lot of sense to criticize the
possibility of boosters right we have
vaccines that are their immunity is
waning over time that's disappointing
and
uh the degree of protection is failing
as a result of the evolution of variants
that escape immunity boosters at best
only correct for the first of those
things
um so anyway the the policy isn't well
thought out and it is uh i think
excellent that people highly placed
in the public health
system are beginning to speak up
indeed
um
yeah i'm not finding
that i find one of those authors on a
lancet paper but that's from last year
i don't find either of them
in a lancet paper this year
oh well
um
i have to find
there we go
can you discuss the u.s
and canadian stance of pasteurized milk
the fda insistence versus the eu stance
risks benefits and juxtapose this with
the current pandemic
that's a lot of questions yeah i don't
see the last one right away but we
actually cover a closely related topic
in the book
right we talk about the fact that milk
is actually one of the few things in the
universe that is supposed to be eaten
right it is designed as a food all right
fruits being another
nectar being a third but it's not most
most critters don't want to be eaten and
anyway
the point is though milk is supposed to
be eaten directly from the breast
and because of that it is not built to
be stable
and so the process of stabilizing there
are lots of ancient ways to stabilize
dairy products you can stabilize them
for a short
period of time as something like yogurt
you can stabilize them for a much longer
period of time as something like cheese
and
cuisine much of cuisine actually uh is
uh the result of
behaviors that we engage in to stabilize
unstable foods or to purify foods that
might be somewhat compromised you know
cooking or sometimes to bring together
ingredients that together make a
complete protein for instance complete
protein to liberate more nutrition from
the same food in any case the point is
pasteurization is a second level
solution to a problem like this if
you're going to take milk and try to
transport it as milk over a long
distance there's only so refrigerated it
can be yeah you could transport cheese
but you can't transport milk unless you
pasteurized pasteurize it right so
pasteurize it is derived from
louis pasteur who demonstrated that
basically life comes from life and
doesn't spontaneously regenerate and
that's why if you heat milk to a
temperature where all of the things that
might be living in it die off and you
keep it hermetically sealed then it
stays
stable so anyway it's a solution to a
problem
does it cause other problems undoubtedly
it does there's also and i don't uh
i do not i would have to look into this
to know exactly where the boundaries
between these issues are but most um
milk in the u.s is both pasteurized and
homogenized as well and i don't think i
don't think that those need to go hand
in hand
and the homogenation the homogenization
process i don't know what it's adding
and
maybe if if all it is adding is
basically uniformity of product and you
don't have to shake right right in order
to get it back into solution um
i think there is
uh some evidence suggesting that
homogenization does have uh negative
effects in terms of for instance just
all the fat globules um that you're
drinking are the same size now as
opposed to different sizes and thus
triggering different things
in your system you know assuming that
you're um that you have lactase
persistence that you have you know that
you have the enzyme that can digest
milk sugars um
that you know as sort of an intermediate
stage could be to pasteurize but not
homogenize milk um as well which again
would you know it's like asking people
to select produce that might not be
quite as pretty
but might actually have more of the
original nutrients because it was grown
in you know dirt versus hydroponically
or something right
i think though this actually makes a
pretty good
test landscape for the model in our book
because you know we've talked on dark
horse about the supply chain length for
food having negative consequences on
things like nutrition we talk in the
book about technology's ancient
technologies for preserving things like
milk like turning them into cheese
we now have newfangled ways of doing
certain things like
pasteurization and homogenization
those things have consequences those
consequences emerge late there's a
question about whether or not the right
thing to do is ignore those consequences
because they're small let those
consequences alter what you're eating
like maybe if your supply chain is so
long that milk can't make it that
distance maybe you'd be better off with
cheese or
something like that and so anyway we're
not going to tell you the answer to
those questions but the point is that's
how you'd set up the problem yeah yeah
right no exactly i mean it's also it's
also of course true that in the u.s you
can um
you can often find small
farms um that will sell you
unpasteurized milk
but that you know de facto the supply
chain is very short there defect of the
supply chain is very short and there's
the perverse incentive surrounding the
litigious instinct and the danger of
disease it's a danger to the farmer for
sure to sell such product right and you
can't imagine a distribution network you
know
to the extent that the occasional person
might get sick from unpasteurized milk
right you expect the system to solve the
problem by potentially making milk less
valuable and possibly even harmful
because
the diseases you might get
from milk that has been degraded in this
way are not going to be something you
can pin on an individual farm or
distributor
at all right whereas if you get um
you know uh e coli
a dangerous e coli infection from a
particular batch of milk that does trace
back to somebody so this is a place
where our system is not biased against
harm it's not obsessed with your safety
what it is is obsessed with not being
able to prove that the harm came from a
particular place and it's a it's a bad
bias
boy and i mean those are inextricably
linked um i think
interesting while you were talking i
came to a slightly different conclusion
which will sound like it is
contradictory i don't think it is i
think both both things are true you know
what you said is it's not the people can
it's not that the system is concerned
with the harm but concerned with being
able to point to what it is that harmed
you yeah um whereas i was thinking
actually
and this was this has sort of been
percolating as we've been having a lot
of these conversations about the book
these last few weeks um that
even more generally than i think we have
thought through before
um the safetyism the safety culture of
childhood and parenting in schools now
is actually true culture-wide and that
we have like we have a society-wide and
this is what the litigious society hands
us as well um society-wide we have like
a safetyism meter and it's turned all
the way to 11. you know this one goes to
11 across every domain everywhere
and it is you know at what cost at what
cost
in some time in some places health in
some places experience in some cases
serendipity risk all of the things that
one learns from actually not having a
single factor turned up so high that
everything else falls off yeah but it
you know i'm not disagreeing with you
and in fact we we uh
wrote this into the book too but
it's not even safetyism right it's like
safety of a particular kind and the
consequence of turning that dial to 11
is to make you desperately unsafe in
some other way
right well but no i mean i think that is
safetyism i think that's you know that
is the
that is the cruel irony of the term that
it is people who are speaking as if and
i believe almost entirely if not
entirely in the case of like what's
happening to children really think
they're making children safer right um
but the effect is precisely the opposite
that doesn't make it not safetyism that
is what it is that is what it's called
but it's not actually increasing safety
right i agree but but somehow i don't i
don't think the world gets this which is
it finds us obsessed with keeping you
safe and it does not understand that we
are obsessed with keeping you safe in
this domain and we manifestly don't give
a [ __ ] in other domains right your
short-term safety
we're obsessed with it right because the
litigious society focuses on these very
directly accessible causes that's right
and we you know
policy kills people in large numbers by
being indifferent to harms that are hard
to prove no and we do say this precisely
in the book and i actually can it could
be so many places i can't remember
exactly where it ended up but the idea
you know a a teenager dies on a school
trip and it's a tragedy and it is also a
story that is relatively easy to tell
and it pulls up the heartstrings and
everyone associated with that trip will
remember it forever and they will be
called back to it by um on the
anniversaries and such
and it can such tragedies can be avoided
by moving towards an almost absolute
safetyism
but the kind of safetyism that then
pervades things like schools who have
who have perhaps had a tragedy and have
then decided to move the slider all the
way to the other side is a greater
tragedy and there may not be deaths that
you can point to as a result but there
will be a society-wide lack of
of potential of capacity of of realized
humanity um because people are unskilled
and too scared to move and too scared to
act it is even the case that if we just
compare trips to trips
right if
you
decide not to have trips because of the
danger of what might happen on a trip
it is impossible to measure how many
lives will be lost because people didn't
go on the kinds of trips in which they
might have learned something about how
to manage risk right and this is a it's
a it's an error it's a it is a tragedy
that our system is biased in favor of
what it can see and
excellent ignoring that which it could
infer but cannot see yes and uh yeah yes
yes
all right that was our answer to
pasteurized milk yes of course right yes
um
i don't know what this means but it's
fascinating so we'll go with it with
quantum effects found in the retinas of
night migratory robins
can we reasonably postulate further
could quantum spins explain a mother's
sense of a child's pain at a distance
i don't know what quantum effects found
in retinas of night migratory robin's
means
um i haven't seen the the finding in
question i don't think it matters to the
question really if you can't assume that
such things are plausible and there
um i'm not saying they are but if you
proceed from that premise
uh
i would say pretty unlikely because you
have much better mechanisms for such
things
um
but it you know it's almost
you know could quantum spins explain
another sense of a child's painting
distance is almost uh what is the
what is the crazy hypothesis that
consciousness predates matter oh uh pan
psychism it's almost a pan psychic
um
it almost
it almost circles back on pan psychism
right which may be a perfectly
viable myth in order to proceed through
life without being a mechanistic
description of anything
and all i would say is
you need to be a little more creative in
thinking about how it is that for
example a mother might detect uh
distress of a child at a distance and
there are lots of mechanisms including
um you know cycles that
the mother may not be aware
of in conscious terms that get disturbed
by distress that when those cycles you
know like when when a room is too quiet
and a mother has a sense of oh wait a
second is there something afoot
somewhere else in the i haven't heard
from the kids in longer than it would
normally be therefore there may be
something going on that i need to check
in on and three times out of four there
isn't anything but one time out of four
you know she catches uh the one she's on
fire
as they sometimes are
um right so anyway i guess my point is
there are lots of ways that don't
require us to hypothesize any force we
don't know about um
that begin to explain you know and this
happens with all sorts of people you you
know somebody has a habit of calling you
at some interval
and they don't call you and you begin to
you know see some part of you is
monitoring the fact that something
doesn't feel right over in that space
or then they do call but it's a little
bit later and you say i was just
thinking of you isn't that amazing well
right exactly right or something in the
timbre of somebody's voice or whatever
um so anyway i think the point is you
don't need
quantum effects to explain what you're
talking about still i'd like to know
about the retinas of the night migratory
right well right yeah yeah i would
um what's your opinion on going to
tanning salons in the winter to boost
vitamin d you know i have actually been
thinking about this very question have
you yeah i totally have which is that
given the role vitamin d seems to play
in terms of
uh preserving health or maybe the way to
say it is that vitamin d
deficiency plays in making one
vulnerable to communicable communicable
diseases in the winter
that there is an argument for
uh
i don't know if it's tanning beds or
rooms or whatever that would
create vitamin d and make people
healthier but it's a you know it's a
pretty good reason to
to do that
so
yeah i don't know i've never looked into
tanning beds um i don't know the you
know sort of uva uvb uvc ratios and um
right what so what but you know you and
i of course land in the same place then
which is there ought to be tanning beds
that are tuned to minimize the risk and
maximize the vitamin d creation but the
chances that they're likely to be the
ones that exist for people to get um
winter tans
indoors
seems small to me right on the other
hand if people understood the connection
between vitamin d deficiency and ill
health then
the market might create more such things
for one thing it's got to be
i don't want to say it has to be but
it's probably pretty close to trivial
to add a setting that would allow you to
dial in
the nature of the tanning device so that
it gave you the optimal thing for
whatever you were trying to accomplish
well i guess one other thing that i
don't know that's relevant to this
question is
whether or not the vitamin d that would
be generated from being exposed to
artificial sun
um
you know how how comparable are these
three things the vitamin d generated by
exposure to the actual sun the vitamin d
generated by exposure to an artificial
sun and the vitamin d encountered by
taking a supplement and it's those last
two categories that um you know that are
maybe what you would be
um
constrained to in the winter and
in general as we write in the book and
as as you know of me i'm not a
fan of supplements i would rather get my
stuff from my food and my activities and
um engaging as uh humans have typically
engaged with the world
but vitamin d seems like a supplement as
far as we can tell is quite effective
quite effective
quite low risk
and so you know if that is true
um why not just take the supplement
why not just take the supplement well i
guess
i mean look i think we have an analogous
question with respect to something like
coffee
okay that
basically
because you've got a complex system that
has detectors on it or in the case of
vitamin d it has synthesizers in the
skin
that there's really just a question of
you know do you want to do you want to
get that update by plugging in an
ethernet cable or do you want to get
that update over the wi-fi and
the coffee
can wake you up in the morning
and you take it in through your gut
and
the same thing would happen if you
stared into
a cool spectrum light as soon as you got
up
right
is there a reason to prefer one of these
i'm sure there's a spectrum of reasons
but it's not obvious to me that the
priority should go to the through the
gut route
uh rather than the the over-the-air
route
well and this is i think then um
i think you're agreeing with me in this
particular case then
that to my surprise i find evidence that
vitamin d supplementation is actually
effective and not particularly costly
and super easy compared to oh i'm gonna
have to go spend an hour a week or
whatever it might be in a tanning bed
like why why wouldn't you if if there is
similar efficacy if as it seems vitamin
d supplementation
um is actually effective and taking it
in the way that our ancestors have
generating vitamin d the way their
answers have generating it have
generated it um doesn't have as many um
different effects as many other things
do
then you know i i would always prefer to
be generating my vitamin d out in the
sun
but then
then if i'm if i'm restricted from that
because of the season
uh and it's a you know a tanning bed
that's been tuned to just right which
may or may not exist in the world yet
versus a pill right in this case i'd
prefer the pill actually yeah i i i
agree on the other hand you could
imagine
um
you know a tanning bed that was tuned so
it did little harm
gave you some tan
and
created vitamin d that would be an
attractive option to people you're
saying i look pale i'm
not saying anything like that darling um
i'm i'm just saying it's not obvious to
me that the pill is the one to bet on
for being
to having the fewest
arbitrary
consequences
um
no i mean conservatively it would be the
opposite the assumption would be
um the opposite i would think
so i
okay next question
what are we at we're at 45 minutes
50 minutes
just finished the book and i love it i
wish i could have been your student and
learned to free myself from fears of
being outside the yellow jacket sting
behind my knee when i was four and
another on top of my foot when i was
nine caused fear that i unfortunately
allowed to control me
anyway the solutions you proposed at the
end of the book aligned so well with
peter joseph's i'm surprised he hasn't
been a guest yet i believe he's a dark
horse and will be integral in building
the bridge to a sane future
interesting you know this name i don't i
don't know this name either all right
well we should look into him peter
joseph um if the mod is there if uh you
would
uh take a note and send that to us so
that we don't lose track since i don't
end up looking back at these questions
with our new system
and reminding myself of past questions
it's going to be another another person
that at least i am not familiar with in
this case i think our excuse is that
apparently he was working in the 1940s
are you familiar with dr raymond reiff
who in the 1940s treated all manner of
disease with light and sound
his work was first lauded then squash
for not being profitable would love to
see it revived and improved upon
it sounds fascinating fascinating you've
not heard of this guy no but it sounds
like he had a sound method
i don't know
you shed some light on the problem
something all right it's getting late
it's what's happening yeah yeah
yeah it is yeah it is no that looks um
and actually if if the mod would also so
that name as well dr raymond
reiff
um would love to look into that the idea
yeah
it's like it's like the doctors who were
treating tuberculosis by taking patients
outside um and then once um
once we had antibiotics which are
amazing and life-saving
instead of enhancing the existing
treatments they were they were replacing
them and so now we had enclosed wards
with no airflow and the treatment of
patients entirely with antibiotics
and and some people got sicker
because um airflow is actually a
tremendous healer and you know the idea
of light and sound i don't know what um
the particulars are here but it sounds
intriguing yep
i found that i have a fantasia i'm
actually not sure if that's aphantasia
or aphantasia i've heard it pronounced
both ways i found i have a fantasia
sounds better the inability to picture
things in your mind's eye
do you have any thoughts on this
condition evolutionary or otherwise
well so inability to picture things in
your minds i've heard of this before and
i always always lose the concept after
afterwards
yeah i mean i wonder about it though
because i did too the fact is
when one i don't have this
uh condition at all but when i try to
picture things in my mind it's not like
looking at them
right it's
uh a partial thing and i'm you know i'm
even pretty good at this i can take um
a complex object and rotate it you know
do things like that sometimes i can did
build a mechanism and kind of run it and
see if if it would actually work in my
opinion or not oh like what kind of
mechanism because that first one is just
like the classic oh men are better at
this than women are right like
3d movement of movement of 3d objects in
space yeah no if i wanted to you know if
we were in the field and i needed to
build a something to solve
some problem right
a pulley driven system or whatever right
and i didn't have the materials that i
wanted for example i could sort of think
through what it would look like and i
could run the twine through the pulleys
and get a sense for how much tension
there would be and whether i think
they're likely to break and you might be
um
mean you actually might be less likely
than i would for instance to want to
draw it out
yeah i've done that it's not that
effective i'm better at conjuring it but
my point is when i do that
you know which i'm able to draw it out
on a piece of paper i mean right if i
conjure it in my mind and i try to look
at it i don't see a picture of it
exactly
it's not held that way so i guess what
i'm saying it's interesting whereas i
totally do like you were
there
like
pulling
got it all right and you're gonna start
including things like oh gotta change
that oh that one's bigger okay
right so when i do that it looks more
like the way things are in dreams which
i described in one of the recent weeks
podcasts as only partially rendered
right
yeah you did and i think that this is
going to be a place where some brands
are very different
i think um
i i end up with stills from dreams
that seem totally rendered to the edges
of consciousness
but they're like like hyper-rendered you
know like some i don't know my art
history well enough to identify the
uh the types of
you know the types of art but you know
some
some art from some periods in history is
just so elaborate like rococo and um
just ridiculous levels of detail or like
you know
posters of the rainforest like this is
the rainforest it's got a jaguar and a
monkey and at the end of porcupine like
it's everything right there it's not
surreal it's not hyper real it's get
real
because the rainforest doesn't look like
that yeah no it's ridiculous
um
but you're saying that it's really it's
more like um
it's like an xkcd comic
it is like that xkcd comic it's also um
the case like if i
uh try to conjure a face of somebody
that i know really well like yours for
example
hard to do in the abstract right it's
hard to hard to do it from memory
um
so anyway i guess the point is you do
want to know what what normal looks like
or given your hypothesis what the range
of normal looks like before you figure
out what the condition you have and how
different it is from because you may be
expecting something that's just not
simply what everybody experiences and
okay i mean this maybe this is the thing
that actually gets us canceled but um oh
god um
you and i have conversations like this
like we've never had that particular
conversation before but um
which reveal
how very different our brains are and
frankly the the shorthand that we used
to describe this stuff what this
particular difference long before we
ever ran into the psychological
description that many psychologists
think is ridiculous and should never be
uttered allowed was
that you are much more auditory and i am
much more visual but that was that was
the language that we used and then
we would see in our students
again long before we ran into um this
you know like visual auditory
kinesthetic you know learning styles um
stuff that you know some psychologists
think is accurate and some say if you
think that you're a [ __ ] you've just
you know you've just
proved that you don't know what you're
doing
i know that my brain is very different
from yours and some of it is exactly in
this area where you know when you say
well you know dreams aren't fully
rendered oh my god i think mine are
right or um oh well when i see things in
my head but i don't really you know i
don't see them as visuals like oh i do
and you know this is this accounts for i
have it much less now but i used to be
able to just say things backwards right
because i see the words in my head as i
as i you know not so much now because
i'm doing so much talking all the time
but used to be whenever whenever i was
thinking about a word it's because i saw
it and so it was perfectly easy to read
it backwards says forwards
and to to you
in this way i would say in this way
you're a normie like you're like what is
that like why would you do how can you
do that and how is it that the words are
showing up for you
um
so i don't
i don't quite understand why so many
psychologists seem eager to dismiss
this kind of difference
as um you know pop psych
clearly bunk when many of the same
people are willing to talk about
neurodiversity
well i i have to say i both resonate
with it right when i read something i
hear it
right right and i certainly right so i
know that that's real i don't think of
myself as auditory and not visual right
right i don't think that's
uh how it works
is there a priority for the auditory
probably right
but anyway i guess the point is until
you describe it correctly you would
expect people to reject it
they falsify it too easily because
the proper response is something like
you know there's an important piece of
truth there but it's not true
um but i i actually i just have not seen
that i haven't seen that pushback yeah
it's always this is nonsense really if
you met people have you talked deeply to
people about how it is that they um form
ideas and and
plan to make things or plan actions yeah
you know like the difference is i i
imagine that we could have we could
discover similar differences and
similarities in for instance how we
wayfind and how we imagine um you know
navigating in the world
and
there's just there's clearly
distinctions to be to be unearthed and
discovered
you sometimes find it
very disturbing if i'm if i'm driving
and i take a way that you know is less
efficient even if it's only very
slightly less efficient and i may have
chosen it for some other reason you're
like immediately like wait a second that
that doesn't make any sense yeah and i
also cannot stand having the voice give
directions it it throws me it makes me
it makes me a less good like i ca i
cannot tolerate it and i think just
having the voice come like no no way no
how ever well i hate it too but i don't
hate it more than missing my exit
because
it was on the screen and i happened to
be thinking about something else and not
looking at the screen and
yeah yeah
anyway
um to be to be continued i expect
any young adult book recommendations on
natural selection and evolution
bookstore science sections are lacking i
have a 16 year old niece advanced reader
majority of adults don't grasp evolution
man all of that is true and the last
time
it was pre-covered but i spent a long
time in the y.a the young adult section
of powell's
uh which is the you know the city of
books here in portland it's
extraordinary an amazing bookstore
and was so disappointed by the offerings
across the board i wasn't even looking
for science
that said
science fiction
might be a place where you can find some
stuff
on the other hand
very little science fiction actually
gets the biology right
yep um you know it depends how how young
is the problem um if you're not that
young
16 year old niece advanced reader oh
then you know that's
what are you thinking i'm thinking
uh
blind watchmaker i'm thinking
uh river out of eden which i have not
read but is obviously targeted to be uh
readily comprehensible
so these are both dawkins books yeah
yeah
um
i guess you know why a as a genre tends
to be fiction yeah and so i read that as
looking for fiction um
but if you're willing to go non-fiction
i haven't read put river out of eden is
that what it is yeah um i haven't read
it um but you know he's he's he's a good
writer and a clear communicator and a
good thinker and um and that that could
work and i would say
um selfish gene
later
it's not the place to start
um
it can be if you know if your college
student is probably the place to start
but if you're
just learning to think this way it's not
the one to start with
does
let's try to do two more here
does evolution decide what traits to
remove
if an organism reproduces successfully
wouldn't that mean every trait would be
passed on great question
um yeah it does decide what to move and
it does it uh in more or less the same
way that it decides how to add something
in fact it's easier to remove things
because they can go latent right so you
can have
i was just thinking about this for some
other reason which i can't remember but
you can have something called a loss of
function mutation where you imagine it
takes up a lot of
a lot of selection in order to
get all of the amino acids in
the resulting protein
to be correct for it to fold into the
shape that does a job but it doesn't
take very many changes to cause it not
to be functional and so anyway there are
loss of function mutations
you can take a gene dormant or latent
and then reactivate it later and so
those are in fact easier processes than
building something up de novo and they
happen the same way which is that
there's variation
in
what is expressed what is in the
phenotype and
when a variation is a savings
um it
provides a competitive advantage to
individuals who have that uh that
savings i will say that in the realm
again this leans heavily towards what we
talk about in the book but
when a trait is
a
is transmitted outside of the genome as
many human traits including many of the
most important human traits are this is
a trivial process right so if you think
about
religions as compendiums of wisdom that
alters behavior in ways that are
adaptive
you have sectarian difference in what
parts of a sacred text to pay attention
to and which parts to de-emphasize and
those individuals that subscribe to a
version of their belief
that is correct that is efficient about
which things not to pay attention to and
which things to retain and they have an
advantage because the behavior is
altered in a way that uh ideally splits
the difference
they will their view of the book and
which things matter
will come to dominate and those who have
some other view where they retain things
that are pointless
will have a disadvantage and their view
will disappear and maybe those who have
the view that uh is on is waning because
it's inefficient will adopt the view
that has become dominant because it
feels like the right thing to do but
anyway the point is selection sorts
things that are not genetically
transmitted even more easily than it
does things that are transmitted in the
genome
very good
good
final question
yes or no
people find it much harder to forgive
someone for being right
than for being wrong
hmm
i think this is true i i also think that
this is true i don't think it's going to
be universal sure it has probably has to
do with the topic and the person well
and how um
how sure you were that you thought they
were wrong yeah
um and what you think the stakes are and
how long it lasted and you know all you
know all of these other factors of
course but if you control for all of
them
i think i think yes
in part
in part because
if a person is wrong
and it's become clear that they're wrong
and they wronged you they owe you an
apology
so they come to you and they give you an
apology but if a person is right
they don't owe you an apology yeah and
so you don't get
in fact you may be the person who has an
apology yep and uh if you were dealing
with having been wrong yourself by
being self-deluded
or um by
by putting you know by having cognitive
dissonance which i guess is form of
self-delusion um and therefore cannot
acknowledge that you were wrong in a way
that actually might warrant an apology
um but some part of you some little part
of you may recognize it that there is an
apology warranted and it's nothing that
can come from the other side
that is going to be
a harder thing to forgive even though
it's not forgiveness um that is that the
person who isn't forgiving is not in a
position that they should be demanding
it i agree
yeah
very insightful question
i think that has taken us to the end of
this week
wow unless you want to pose a question
no
god no
this week the better really i don't know
i don't think you mean that no i don't
really mean you know what tomorrow is i
do
it's sunday
[Laughter]
our producer is snort laughing in the
background because you just walked into
a little mess for that you made of
yourself didn't you well i thought i
knew what day it was and i'm right and
you're having trouble forgiving me for
it is that what's going on yes yes it is
i forgive you for being right in a very
very limited way
um
what i was going to say you know fall is
coming and you're going to need me
during the fall you'll see
tomorrow is a day on which neither of us
need to be on screen at all what i know
no screen anywhere no screen amazing and
i think that is
a wonderment we really do enjoy doing
these um and um so appreciate the
audience and are so grateful for you
guys um but we have also been spending
way too much time way too much time
right here staring into cameras
but just because we will not be
uh
looking into cameras does not mean we
will not be appearing on a screen near
you
congratulations or our apologies
depending upon how you view that but um
in any case yeah tomorrow we will not be
looking into cameras tomorrow we will
not be looking into cameras
um so uh again i'll just i will just end
by uh suggesting that you like that you
share
uh this video if you liked it uh and
that you subscribe to the channels and
that if you
um you find find a way to get a copy of
the book if you're if you're here this
long you're probably interested and so
you know buy it or
borrow it from a library from a friend
and read it and after you do if you
would uh leave a review that would be
wonderful
anything to say before i sign us out i
don't think so all right
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
you